[Musique]
avez vous déjà injuria un autre
conducteur
si vous avez répondu oui vous êtes comme
70% des français
et attendez on passe à fait ça fait un
an que tout le monde est dans la merde à
cause dans les yeux
alors va te dire je vais pas terminée
dix ans après pratiquement tout au nom
mais pas dans la merde à cause de
dirigeants de la mer ça coûte une
politique talbi répondait à m e division
alors je vous dis une chose je ne
comprends pas votre discours qui sert
certainement très juste moi je suis
approximatif mais moi j'ouvre les yeux
tous les gens du milieu scolaire et que
j'arriverais à rien et il y avait un
prof qui m'avait dit mathieu faut savoir
un truc c'est que ce sont les tonneaux
vides qui font le plus de bruit
donc on voit il a enseigné vraiment que
tu es que je t'es con quoi toi six
matchs par jour qui qui qui tombent à
leur guise on attendait des buteurs il
avait pu affirmer tout bon est fermée
hier une icône au siom jeudi rires sinon
il se sent ce que monsieur monsieur
attendait ça
je pense que c'est pour me déstabiliser
du pur déstabilise mans bon alors donc
j'attends laisser faire ça ça s'appelle
monsieur s'appelle du pathos mais c'est
pas fait ça en privé des infectiologues
cogne les scientifiques sont plus
écoutés que les politiques et c'est ça
qui agace macron un autre ajoute peut
plus nous voir en peinture
pour l'instant je ne vois pas comment on
peut échapper au confinement mais il
faut le souligner iphone extrémistes
alors là oui il va falloir que ce soit
assez rapide parce que ils les français
vont comprendre quelque chose qu'il faut
leur expliquer je sais le terme
confinement près préventive mais n'est
pas accepté par le politique mais nous
nous nous dans le boulot c'est de la
prévention
vous est il déjà arrivé de ne pas
respecter les distances de sécurité
72 % des conducteurs français commettent
cette faute sur nom assez de vivre sans
de vivre sans horizon de vie vos sens en
espace vital
ils en ont assez génial ou bien sûr mais
c'est pour ça que leur espace vital sera
d'autant plus réduit que les mesures
seront prises tardivement
et ce mannequin
le directeur de sciences po paris
emporté par la sphère duhamel
fredericlyon démissionne de son poste
les étudiants faisait pression depuis
que la faire avec l'ani lui reprocher de
dire qu'il ne savait pas alors qu'il
avait reconnu avoir été alerté en 2018
par aurélie filippetti ces mouvements là
sont très embêtés avec l'histoire
olivier duo mais parce que ça ne
rentrent pas dans leur case vous
comprenez olivier duhamel c'est un homme
de gauche
ce n'est pas une femme qui est victime
ça c'est un truc extraordinaire c'est un
garçon il n'y a pas de femmes victimes
et il n'y a pas d'homme de droite
méchant prédateurs y en a là dedans y'a
un cerveau l'attend dans cette boîte
crânienne
selon nos confrères de l'express qui
publie une grande enquête sur le
journaliste eric zemmour penserait pas
seulement en se rasant à se lancer dans
la course à la présidentielle
en tout cas elle en parle ouvertement à
ses proches
la gueule à l'opinel la page et les
c'est ça
on est tous des frères
un discours très dur contre
l'immigration par exemple la migration
vous êtes d'accord avec ça bah écoutez
je ne suis pas graphiquement je suis
allé en afrique ne dit pas non mais
c'est même plus la peine de commencer
comme ça mais je vous assure qu'on peut
parler d'eux ne s'est pas la peine de
précautions oratoires
le vendeur était contacté par l'expert
le vendeur prétend que ce n'est pas lui
qui a trafiqué les compteurs sont les
gens du voyage il est de mauvaise foi
moi je préfère aller en justice
attention parce que vu ce qu'on vienne
me dire là ça c'est lui qui le dit c'est
dit nous dit vu moi j'écoute tout le
monde justement pour essayer de dettes à
la hauteur des gg qui sont des groupes
trop chaud et bah je peux vous assurer
que des fois il parle je ne comprends
rien non mais je vous dis ouais c'est
vrai j'ai pas fais pas de plus est un
désolé à fort il n'a pas que des amis
jean jacques brot et notamment les élues
locales qui conteste sa présence locale
comment les élus le couple et j'ai dit
quoi lol c'est pas grave parce que l'on
a enregistré on va le coupé un accord
inédit entre lvmh et la municipalité de
vendôme cette ville de 41 mille
habitants dans le loir et cher cette son
nom de marque au groupe qui pourra la
poser sur des collections de bijoux un
nom aux parfums de luxe dont la ville
vient de vendre l'utilisation 10000
euros au groupe lvmh
un prix qui pourrait paraître dérisoire
mais le maire de la ville des forces
choix il assure que la ville de vendôme
ne cède pas son nom à louis vuitton mais
seulement la marque vendôme il fait
concurrence à personne demain l'office
du tourisme peut continuer à voir les
porte clés à l'éffigie de vendôme
moi j'ai ma tasse de café qui me qui me
quitte jamais et je la montre
volontairement qu'elle noyau vendôme
je peux encore utiliser ma tasse de café
y en aura d'autres mains y a pas de
sujet
ils n'hésitent plus à aller à la
confrontation
comme ce cycliste qui filme un scooter
en infraction c'est une piste cyclable
vous sortez monsieur durand sortir
mettront ces cinq ans une fois mais le
tas avait rejeté le projet caméra sans
cas d'accident annoncée d'oussama
[Musique]
effectivement l'avocat texan rod benson
un filtre chat sur le visage lors d'une
audience en ligne
le juge tente de l'aider mais c'est un
peu la panique et les engueuler d'or
d'or d'or ta gueule et à ce moment là
josiane toujours dans le micro est bien
debout a dit je veux bien sortir je veux
bien [__] le camp
mais je veux qu'on me le demande
gentiment